Fabiano wants to score at least 6.5 points
on an important chess competition.
He gets one point for each game he wins,
and 0.5 points for each game that ends in a draw.
Write an inequality that shows the number of games,
which Fabiano must win,
and finish it equally to achieve its goal.
I recommend that you pause the video and see if it is
you can do it.
Write inequalities in terms of number of games,
which he won, marked with mainly "W",
and the number of games completed in a row, marked with "D",
which presents what he should do,
to achieve its goal.
Okay, let's do it together.
How many points will he get from victories?
If he wins in W games
and received one point for each of them,
there will be one point of play in the number of games.
1 on W can write it only as W.
These are the points of the victories.
And how many points will he draw from the draw?
He will have D draws
and will receive 0.5 points for each of them.
0.5 by D will be the points of the games that have ended in a draw.
And this here will be his common points,
points of victory and draw points.
I assume that he does not get any points at a loss.
As he wants the total number of points he receives,
be at least 6.5.
He wants this to be greater than or equal to 6.5.
If it is said that Fabiano wants to win more than 6.5 points,
then it will be greater than.
But it is said that Fabiano wants to score at least 6.5 points,
so we have greater than or equal to 6.5.
He will be pleased if he scores 6.5 points.
And here we wrote the inequality of the number of games,
which he has to win or end in a draw,
this inequality must be true,
to gain at least 6.5 points
of this important chess competition.